christopher nolan's 2020 sci-fi action
thriller tennis is absolutely packed
with exciting plot twists
and complex concepts so you probably
didn't pick up on everything in your
first or even
fifth viewing keep watching to discover
some of the small details you may have
missed
if you've watched tennis then you have a
basic understanding of time inversion
you know there are turn styles that can
reverse an object's entropy
allowing that object to move backwards
through time but processing who is
and isn't inverted can be a tedious task
lucky for us the makers of tennis lace a
film with colour theory to help us
figure everything out
in the final battle soldiers are given
armbands that are either blue
or red to indicate whether or not
they're inverted red signifies an object
that's not inverted
and moving with the usual flow of time
while blue signifies an object that's
inverted
and moving against the flow of time
these identifiers are actually scattered
throughout the film
when seder is tormenting his wife cat
she's sporting a bright red dress
and when the protagonists and neil find
the first turnstiles at freeport
the doors they walk through a lay board
with red and blue signs
the most notable colour rich moment
comes when sata interrogates the
protagonist
and shoots cat with an inverted round
the room is bathed in blue light on one
side
while the other side of the glass is lit
with red paying attention to the reds
and blues will make another viewing of
tennis a completely different experience
after the protagonist wakes up from his
pill that puts him in a coma he is
greeted by an official who informs him
of the existence of tenet
an organization fighting an onslaught
from the future the protagonist is
informed that using the word will launch
him further down the rabbit hole
you might think that the word is used
this way only once when he meets with
scientists to learn the mechanics of
time inversion
but it's actually dropped in
conversation by other people in subtle
ways
when the protagonist executes the
reverse bungee jump with neil he then
meets priya
the supplier of an inverted bullet found
earlier and she tells him something very
important
to say anything about a client would
violate a tenant she lives by
from priya's perspective she's already
met the protagonist
though he hasn't met her yet this is a
sneaky way for her to check which
version of the protagonist she's talking
to
her dialogue also tells us that she's
viewing the conceptual core with a many
worlds mentality
which is incorrect she alludes to this
during an ominous conversation when she
states
if that universe can exist we don't live
in it
her inability to correctly process cause
and effect as non-linear
results in a bullet from the protagonist
the most hard-hitting scene in tenet is
undoubtedly when we discover that the
inverted man the protagonist battled at
freeport is actually himself
after cat is hit with an inverted round
the crew invert themselves in order for
the wound to properly take its course
without killing her
in order to flip back around again they
venture back to freeport to jump into
the turnstiles that they found the week
before
their plan is to sneak in during the
panic after the plane crashed from the
earlier heist a hypnotic sequence and
takes place in which they are running
through the crash site
while the world moves in reverse around
them it's after this shot that the
protagonist has stressed into his
altercation with himself
the fight likely distracted you from
some neat little details like the
protagonist's view of running out to
tell neil that it's all clear
which cuts to neil's perspective as he
watches the protagonist
run by in reverse the group hijacks an
ambulance and are able to escape the
scene unharmed for the most part
a clever detail emerges as they are
driving off in the ambulance
as you can see the inverted version of
the characters moving backwards away
from the plane crash
with cat on the gurney this is just one
of several moments when tennis
characters are completely unaware that
they're passing by different inverted
versions of themselves
turn it isn't a time travel movie in the
typical sense consider neil and the
protagonist discussion of the
grandfather paradox which posits that if
you were to go back in time and kill
your own grandfather
you would cease to exist thereby
resulting in a logical loop what's the
answer
there's no answer it's paradox
supposedly the people of the future
believe that if they harm their own
grandfather
there won't be consequences or at least
none more severe than the planetary doom
they're already marching towards
if their line of thinking is correct
then the fact that everything is taking
place
means that they failed had they
succeeded in triggering the algorithm
then time wouldn't be flowing in our
direction this could also be true
according to some of the film's other
events
like cat killing satyr in the past this
would mean that the past can be affected
without consequence
because there's a version of sata
running a mark long after his demise
this is actually left ambiguous as some
of the dialogue tells us that there is a
possibility that this is a future
version of sata
this would mean that satar and cat both
inverted and came back to the same
moment
so in reality we still don't know which
take on the grandfather paradox is true
within the world of tenet
that feels about right for a christopher
nolan mind bender
an early step on the protagonist's path
to getting close to sata is their sail
boat adventure
cat is also on board and she takes the
opportunity to unhook sata's harness
and send him tumbling into the water
nearly killing him
the protagonist's rescue helps him move
closer within sata's circle
but this scene has even more meaning to
it than that different parts of this
sequence are presented as a visual
metaphor for the movie's time mechanics
consider the color of the sailboat for
example it's blue
it's so blue in fact that it feels
intentional with this in mind
it's worth noting the shot of the
sailboat turning around against the
current
this is a nod to how time inversion
works it moves upstream
against the usual flow of time after the
protagonist is told about tinnit he's
dropped off at sea among a scattering of
windmills
you probably assumed at this point that
he's waiting for another bow to take him
further to his next destination
while he's waiting he climbs a ladder
inside the windmill and does some
bullets
during a first watch this routine
probably seems to exist
only to display his level of discipline
but this scene comes back into play in a
brief moment later on
in that subsequent scene the protagonist
is inverted and he travels back to the
day an explosion occurs in styles
12 which happens at the same time as he
are proceeded in the opening scene
while working his way back there's a
shot of him on a big yellow budge
doing pull-ups as the ship moves in
reverse this area of the ocean is
actually the same windmill filled area
seen earlier
thus the scene shows a protagonist
moving by his past self
also when his earlier version leaves the
windmill it's on a blue boat
while all other boats on the water are
red in the later scene on the yellow
barge
you can see a blue boat moving backwards
next to a couple of red boats
remember the entire movie is a
palindrome there are a slew of confusing
moments all throughout senate and
wrapping your brain around each one of
them can cause a bit of a headache
but one thing we're pretty sure we can
say with certainty is that neil is
marching towards his doom the last time
we see him
while the protagonist is down in the
cavern trying to procure the algorithm
he spots a piece of red string on the
backpack of the inverted soldier
who's lying dead on the other side of
the locked gate as neil is walking away
we see that same piece of red string on
his backpack
this isn't the first time in tennant
that we see that key piece of string
in the opening scene the protagonist is
a player in the opera heist there's a
moment when he's rescued by what appears
to be a man wielding an inverted bullet
as the man turns to run off the
protagonist spots that same piece of
string on his backpack
this means that the protagonist was
being saved by neil before they ever
actually met
some tenet theories made the assumption
that the pill the protagonist takes at
the beginning of the film successfully
killed him
they claim that we are witnessing his
end and that the movie is moving towards
how it all started but the dialogue when
he wakes
up makes it clear that that is not the
case although that pill has come back
into play later on
when satyr is contemplating his eventual
suicide he holds up that same pill and
reveals that he borrowed it from the cia
he goes on to describe it as a way that
the world ends
this means that satar is unaware of the
fact that the pillars are fake
and it also means that if cat doesn't
kill sata he will still fail to set off
the algorithm by killing himself
this is basically indicating that sata
was always going to lose
no matter what course of action he takes
whatever's happened
happened a common complaint about
christopher nolan films is their
incredibly loud soundtracks
sometimes they can overwhelm the
dialogue and in a movie like tennis the
dialogue is extremely important
it's the situation that can be easily
remedied with subtitles at least
we can then be content with the sound
levels because they can't deny how
effective the score is in setting the
mood
moreover there are several key moments
in which tennis music is particularly
creative
and dramatically important composer
ludwig gorinson used a creative approach
to ensure that turnit's score
mirrors the film's themes at various
moments such as the interrogation scene
the music is playing backwards this
detail is so intricate and
important that gorinson didn't just
reverse the soundtrack
he actually had his musicians play the
music backwards it's not the only time
he played with the music this way
during the final battle there are two
different scores playing over each other
so as to match a battlefield featuring
inverted and non-inverted soldiers
grandson went even further in some
scenes when the protagonist is on a boat
with both inverted and non-inverted
soldiers training behind him
the music has its rhythm and percussion
playing forward or the orchestra is
playing in reverse
as neil marches off to rejoin the battle
once again he declares
the whole operation is a temporal
printer that statement helps us better
understand the movie as a whole
like how the ending occurs at the same
time as the opening during the
conclusion the protagonist is part of a
battle in stalsk
12 where everyone is fighting over the
algorithm the soldiers we see are
performing a temporal pincer
in the traditional military sense a
pincer involves attacking your enemy
from two different
directions if you take that concept and
correlate it with time
it means that the soldiers are attacking
from two different directions in time
the window of time that the soldiers
work with is 10 minutes on either side
of the event
everything that christopher nolan does
when making his films as intentional and
this chosen amount of time is no
exception
the word tenet spells ten both forwards
and backwards
thus the title of the movie itself hints
to what is going to happen
compared to the other details covered on
this list this particular one is rather
simple
but it's nevertheless dizzyingly cool
when you actually notice it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]